the first time we were hearing from a
family member who lost both her son and
her husband on the Titan submersible it
imploded on its way down to the wreck
and all five people on board are
presumed dead an exclusive conversation
with our partners at the BBC Christine
Dogwood said the dive had been a big
adventure for her entire family
I was really happy for them because both
of them though really really wanted to
do that for a very long time so it was
supposed to be shazada and I going down
um and then I stepped back and gave this
place to Suleiman because he really
wanted to go the other victims include
another paying guest a renowned Titanic
expert and the submersibles owner the
U.S Coast Guard and Canada's
Transportation safety board are now
investigating the cause of the accident